we will now go through an example which
is essentially a drill to consolidate
our understanding of the conditional
expectation and the conditional variance
consider a random variable X which is
continuous and is described by a PDF of
this form whenever we have a PDF that
seems to consist of different pieces
it's always useful to divide and conquer
and the way we will do that will be to
consider two different scenarios that X
falls in this range and in that scenario
we say that the certain random variable
Y is equal to 1 and another scenario in
which X falls in this range and in that
case we say that Y is equal to 2 let us
now look at the conditional expectation
of x given Y what is it well it is a
random variable which can take different
values depending on what Y is if Y
happens to take a value of 1 then we are
in this range and the conditional PDF of
X given that Y falls in this range keeps
the same shape its uniform and so it's
mean is going to be equal to the
midpoint of this interval which is 1/2
and this is something that happens when
y is equal to 1 what is the probability
of this happening the probability that Y
is equal to 1 is the area under the PDF
in this range and since the height of
the PDF is 1/2 this probability is 1/2
the alternative scenario is that Y
happens to take the value of 2 in which
case X lives in this interval given that
X has fallen in this interval the
conditional expectation of X is the
midpoint of this interval and the
midpoint of this interval is at 2 and
this is an event that again happens with
probability 1/2 because the area under
the PDF in this region is equal to 1/2
so the conditional expectation is a
random variable that takes these values
with these probabilities
since we now have a complete
probabilistic description of this random
variable we are able to calculate the
expectation of this random variable what
is it with probability 1/2 the random
variable takes the value of 1/2 and with
probability 1/2
it takes the value of 2 and so the
expected value of the conditional
expectation is 5 over 4 but the law of
iterated expectations tells us that this
quantity is also the same as the
expected value of x so we have managed
to find the expected value of x by the
divide-and-conquer method by considering
different cases let us now turn to the
conditional variance of x given Y once
more this quantity is a random variable
the value of that quantity depends on
what Y turns out to be and we have again
the same two possibilities Y could be
equal to 1 or Y could be equal to 2 and
these possibilities happen with equal
probabilities if Y is equal to 1
conditional on that event X has a
uniform PDF on this range on an interval
of length 1 and we know that the
variance of a uniform PDF on an interval
of length 1 is 1 over 12 if on the other
hand Y takes the value of 2 then X is a
uniform random variable on an interval
of length 2 and the variance in this
case is 2 squared where these two stands
for the length of the interval divided
by 12 which is the same as 4 over 12 so
we now have a complete probabilistic
description of the conditional variance
as a random variable it's a random
variable that with these probabilities
takes these two particular values since
we know the distribution of this random
variable we can certainly calculate its
expected value and the expected value is
found as follows with probability 1/2
the random variable of interest takes
the value of 1 over 12 and with
probability 1/2
this random variable takes a value of 4
over 12 and this number happens to be 5
over 24 finally let us calculate the
variance of the conditional expectation
since we have complete information about
the distribution of the conditional
expectation calculating its variance is
not going to be difficult so what is it
with probability 1/2 the conditional
expectation takes a value of 1/2 we
subtract from this the mean of the
conditional expectation which is 5 over
4 and we take the square of that so this
term is the square of the deviation of
the value of the random variable of 1/2
from the mean of that random variable
and we get a similar term if Y happens
to be equal to 2 with probability 1/2
our random variable takes a value of 2
which is so much away from the mean of
the random variable and then we square
that quantity if we carry out the
algebra the answer turns out to be 9
over 16 and now we can go back to the
law of the total variance and calculate
that the total variance is equal to the
expected value of the variance which is
5 over 24 and then we have the variance
of the expected value which is 9 over 16
and this number evaluates to 37 over 48
so we have managed to find the variance
of this random variable using the divide
and conquer method and the law of the
total variance